[Music]
these are the must-see 2017 grammy
red-carpet moments Paris Jackson stunned
in a sparkly ball Mon gone Adele also
turned heads in this gorgeous screams
Yvonne she gown a departure from her
usual black dresses and check out
Camilla Kibeho in this silver
princess-esque number this is the
eighteen-year-olds first red carpet
appearance since splitting from fifth
harmony meanwhile Lady Gaga went for a
gothic biker chic look and debuted this
moth tattoo on her back in a revealing
look joy Villa opted to make a political
statement showing her support for
president Donald Trump and his
controversial make America great again
gown for Diplo it was a family affair on
the carpet laser and that's luck it this
is a family affair yes
yeah because matching suits today this
is the first red carpet blink-182
drummer Travis Barker also brought his
kids
thirteen-year-old Landon and 11 year
olds Alabama who stole the show in this
pink gown and check out Rihanna rocking
a sexy black and orange Halloween
inspired look and showing off her abs in
that crop top finally supermodel Heidi
Klum was all about her legs in this
super short sparkly silver Minnie
[Music]
you